we are now joined by the mayor of yuma
arizona mayor douglas nichols mayor
thank you for joining us in steve's
reporting there great reporting down
from eagle pass texas he mentioned that
president biden then candidate biden
said that there wasn't going to be any
building of new wall that is an
understatement let us play for you
exactly what he said listen
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed on my administration i'm
going to make sure that we have border
protection but it's going to be based on
making sure that we use high-tech
capacity to deal with it and at the
ports of entry
but now as we know mr mayor in four
areas they are reversing themselves and
building onto the trump wall your
reaction
i think it's great i think it's a very
practical move um it's something that
we've obviously been advocating for a
year and a half now so it's great that
it's actually going to be here in a few
more months although i i do believe and
i'm hearing a little bit of rumor that
it won't look like the trump wall it'll
probably be a more of a
a different type of barrier but a
positive barrier in any case will be a
big drum and a dramatic improvement for
the uh that section of the border where
uh we have just a lot of people coming
through about 50 of the traffic in human
sector comes through that one area
do you believe mr mayor that the
administration is perhaps quietly but
not admittingly
trying to realize they have a crisis
indeed on their hands and they need to
do something and they're finally
listening to border patrol officials who
say infrastructure works
i think that's true i think you know
any anybody looks at these numbers and
they can't say that everything's fine
you have to recognize that these numbers
are historical there's nothing like this
ever before ever anywhere in this
country's history so what we're what
needs to be done is what's starting to
get done and it's a slow turn but you
know decades before this wasn't a
partisan issue this was just a a
practical on the ground type of of issue
and so hopefully the administration's
going back to that kind of perspective
and take the politics out of it and just
get what's needed
for the border are they doing enough mr
mayor because in yuma arizona you are in
that sector the third busiest in the
nation you've had 35 migrant deaths this
fiscal year a stat not made public by
border patrol but one that i have uh
from my border patrol sources and yet it
doesn't seem that it's getting any
better
and actually i think those numbers are
even higher because that doesn't include
like we had a couple people pass away
within the city limits which this police
department responded to instead of
border patrol so it is definitely a huge
issue and
having
something that is going in the right
direction is great it is a first step
there are many more steps that need to
get done but without this first step
we'll never get to the other one so this
is a
movement in the right direction um
arizona has encountered nearly 265
000 migrants this fiscal year three more
months to go but here in washington
where i am our mayor d.c mayor muriel
bowser is calling it a humanitarian
crisis after receiving just 4 000
migrants here in the nation's capitol
here's some of what she had to say about
calling in the national guard listen
we need space uh and we we need the
federal government to be involved so
i've asked for the deployment of the
guard as long as we need the guard to
deal with the humanitarian crisis that
we expect to escalate the number of
people crossing the border seeking
asylum we expect to only go up
what do you make of it
well i think it's great they're joining
conversation this is something we've
been talking about for over a year and a
half and to finally have these other
mayors that understand are beginning to
understand what that
impact is you know
washington dc is millions of people
and they're concerned about 4 000 people
we get over 5 000 people in a week
through the yuma area and we're only a
community of 100 000 people so if
they're finally getting to the
understanding that uh this is a bigger
issue than just for the little towns
along the border i think it's a great
thing
yeah and you can see here on our screen
these are migrants that have been
dropped off outside of union station
sleeping there it's a very sad
humanitarian crisis indeed the mayor's
right and she's pointing to the fact
that this is a federal
responsibility do you believe this
administration is abdicating that
responsibility
well i believe they are but it's not in
washington d.c they are doing that
actually at the border when they they
facilitate the processing of people to
come in to wait the five to six years
for a judge
there needs to be a change that that
stops that process otherwise all we're
doing is continuing the process of
trafficking that the cartels started
so the federal government needs to find
ways policies
different just enforcing the laws that
are on the books would then help stop
that traffic from happening and end up
in a situation like in washington dc in
just in the 30 seconds or so we've got
mr mayor the other thing that the
cartels are taking advantage of an open
border is pushing
drugs particularly the deadly drug
fentanyl across what are you seeing in
the hume area well we're since border
patrol is finally able to get back to
some of the border protection activity
we're actually seeing an increase in the
number of apprehensions of smugglers as
well as
actual drugs being caught but there's
still a dramatic number of of uh traffic
amount of trafficking that is probably
not getting caught and still getting
into the interior of the united states a
lot we don't know about more than 500
000 known got aways that's a story for
another day and a concerning one indeed
mr mayor thank you for taking time yuma
mayor doug nichols thank you very much
sir hey everyone i'm emily compagno
catch me and my co-host harris faulkner
and kaylee mcanenny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12pm eastern or set your dvr
also don't forget to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page for daily
highlights